these days when you reach for a camera
it's the one on your phone they can take
great images if you learn how to work
with light and use the right apps the
best starting point for this is vscocam
it's free and it's one of the best start
to finish photo apps out there it has a
great interface with really easy
controls for adjusting things like focus
exposure is oh and white balance even
the default camera and iOS and Android
will let you control some of these
things but the full-featured shooting
apps like pro camera allow for much
finer control letting you play with
features like shutter speed and white
balance if you want beautifully lit
photos make use of the Sun when you're
shooting a portrait look for the
brightest spot in the room and set up
the shot there you'll also want to avoid
the digital zoom because it just
degrades your photo quality the only
zoom you need is your own two feet move
closer to your subject until they fill
the frame and if you want to get really
fancy with visco try the level line up
the vertical and horizontal lines until
they turn into one green bar and you'll
never again have a crooked photo when it
comes to editing you'll get the best
results if you keep things settle bump
up the brightness just a bit increase
the contrast and give your saturation an
edge this helps keep the dark tones nice
and inky while giving your colors a
little pop you can do these edits in any
app whether it's the same app you use to
take the picture or a dedicated editing
app like darkroom Snapseed or n light
these apps won't make you an amazing
photographer overnight but if you play
around with the controls and really pay
attention to how the different settings
affect your photos you'll learn all the
basics of photography and if for some
crazy reason you end up using a regular
camera again you'll know how to use it
even better